[Applauso]
oggi sono qui a rappresentare
un gruppo un gruppo di ingegneri e
architetti un gruppo inclusivo che tende
ad accogliere persone che vogliono
confrontarsi con gli stessi temi con cui
ci stiamo confrontando noi ormai da
undici anni più o meno un gruppo il cui
nucleo fondatore ha iniziato a lavorare
in un ambito universitario in ambito di
ricerca universitari ci siamo conosciuti
tutti in un dottorato di ricerca
questo lo strato dice che ha cominciato
a starci un po stretto a un certo punto
fare solo ricerca teorica non è
esattamente quello che vuole fare un
architetto un ingegnere ha bisogno di
confrontarsi con qualcosa di più
concreto e questo è quello che abbiamo
cercato di fare è quindi iniziato a fare
ricerca applicata la ricerca applicata
però per noi doveva avere un senso e il
senso abbiamo trovato con una mission
molto molto precisa che è quella di
cercare di portare il bello e la qualità
dove la qualità non c'è quindi abbiamo
iniziato ad occuparci di contesti di
emergenza umanitaria
l'emergenza umanitaria come vedete può
essere in contesti di guerra o in
contesti di disastri naturali o contesti
in cui la marginalità è il problema
fondamentale
il punto è riuscire a confrontarsi con
tutti i temi che possiamo mettere in
gioco nel momento in cui interveniamo in
situazioni di questo genere possono
essere appunto come dicevo prima il
bello la bellezza che ha una influenza
straordinaria in contesti di questo
genere per iniziare un processo di
cambiamento e dall'altra parte
l'efficienza il fatto di costruire
contesti architetture che abbiano un
confort molto elevato che non sia
soltanto un dovuto ad aria condizionata
o elementi di questo genere ma che nasca
dall'architettura stessa quindi
lavorando con quello che noi chiamiamo
principi passivi di architettura
bioclimatica
per fare questo noi viaggiamo viaggiamo
molto
il viaggio è uno degli aspetti
fondamentali che trattiamo e che è che
come direi viviamo quasi quotidianamente
domani o un aereo
infatti sono qui a correre per poter
tornare in fretta il viaggio però non è
soltanto un viaggio fisico
più vado avanti in questa attività e più
mi rendo conto di quanto di quanto di
fatto è sempre un riconoscersi e un
rincontrarsi è un viaggio dentro dentro
di noi ma dentro alle potenzialità che
abbiamo noi più è strano il luogo in cui
andiamo più lontano da noi luogo in cui
andiamo riusciamo a trovare risposte in
quello che ci siamo dimenticati di
quello che il nostro patrimonio
culturale e di conoscenza e il viaggio è
una sorta di catalizzatore del processo
creativo e ci mette in discussione in
ogni scelta che facciamo nel momento in
cui dobbiamo risolvere un problema è
dove abbiamo spesso risolvere in fretta
in contesti di emergenza ma il viaggio
anche conoscenza non è solo una
conoscenza che è arrivata dentro di noi
ma è la conoscenza del diverso
dell'estraneo di quello che è che fuori
di noi ma meglio ancora meglio è quello
che di noi troviamo nell'altro e spesso
ci rendiamo conto che non c'è molta
differenza non c'è molta distanza tra
noi e gli altri anche se andiamo
dall'altra parte del mondo
siamo architetti siamo ingegneri come vi
dicevo prima e quindi i nostri temi
fondamentali sono delle ricerche per
esempio sui materiali materiali che
usiamo sono sempre o materiali naturali
quindi lavoriamo con con la paglia che
per esempio il materiale estremamente
efficiente anche in questa parte del
mondo in termini di isolamento termico
lavoriamo con il bambù adesso stiamo
lavorando in myanmar per esempio creando
una serie di strutture in bambù l'avremo
con la terra cruda stiamo facendo dei
lavori in albania in questo momento in
terra cruda o lavoriamo con materiali
riciclati o ancora meglio riutilizzati
come abbiamo fatto in palestina
utilizzando dei pneumatici dismessi
riempiti di terra che hanno dato vita a
un edificio estremamente iconico e molto
performante dal punto di vista delle
performance delle performance climatiche
e quindi aumentando terribilmente la
qualità della vita dei bambini si
trattava di una scuola che andavano a
lezione in mezzo al deserto tecniche le
tecniche ci dicono moltissimo di quello
che sono le ragioni di un luogo sono
esatte sono la sintesi tra ragioni
culturali e ragioni climatiche sono
spessissimo quello che possiamo
il frutto di quello che possiamo andare
a incontrare in in un luogo quindi
possono essere dalla volta nubiana a a
tecniche più più moderne come gli sci in
cui invece mettiamo in gioco materiali
di riciclo e riutilizzati rimettendo i
materiali in un meccanismo di economia
circolare in grado di dare nuova vita a
materiali altrimenti destinati alla
morte
la tecnologia per noi però ha un duplice
valore anche il processo di conoscenza
che ci porta a a lavorare nei contesti
in cui andiamo a lavorare per noi e allo
stesso piano la conoscenza teorica e la
conoscenza pratica il fare e il pensare
le mani e il cervello sono allo stesso
livello
non possiamo andare a costruire in
situazioni di marginalità estreme senza
avere strumenti che sono gli strumenti
che potremmo avere qui senza misurarci
direttamente con quello che sono i
problemi che andremo a incontrare per
fare questo l'esperienza dei luoghi
della conoscenza profonda lì dove
andiamo a lavorare e la conoscenza
ripeto della tecnica dei materiali dei
dettagli che andremo a costruire sono
fondamentali ma non solo in una come per
una questione tecnica anche e
soprattutto per la costruzione di una
comunità nel cercare di arrivare insieme
ad una ad una conclusione arrivare
insieme alla risoluzione di un problema
che un po prende la distanza è quello
che è un approccio più universitario più
accademico in cui invece è tutto già
detto in qualche modo sperimentato si
può dire solo quello che qualcuno ha già
detto prima di te
e questo è un po il nostro approccio no
il nostro viaggio inizia sempre con un
ritorno con qualcosa che accade priva
prima di partire e quindi la
sperimentazione un workshop fra di noi
in cui sperimentiamo quello che andremo
a fare
misuriamo con la fatica quello che
andiamo a proporre facciamo quello che
poi faremo insieme alle comunità in cui
andiamo a lavorare che spesso sono
comunità molto piccole molto come dire
lontane anche dal nostro modo di
comunicare e quindi l'insieme attraverso
un processo che diventa una sorta di
boys chiamerebbe scultura sociale
cerchiamo di arrivare a degli obiettivi
comuni attraverso un processo che è
comune prendendo le distanze da quello
che è il tipico ego dell'architetto in
cui bisogna di mostrare i muscoli
dimostrare quanto sia grandi ma cercando
di lavorare in modo corale insieme
questo è uno è parte del gruppo degli
ormai dottor a dottori di ricerca dei
fondatori del gruppo come vi dicevo poi
va sintetizzato il lavoro fatto
attraverso questo workshop e quindi
creiamo e questo è il momento in cui si
incontra la teoria con la pratica
attraverso una sorta di manuale di
istruzione il il lavoro il come andremo
a costruire questo è fondamentale sia
per costruire ma anche per riuscire a
mantenere gli edifici perché spesso in
situazioni di marginalità quando uno
costruisce lascia qualcosa viene
lasciato a se stesso e non viene
mantenuto invece il nostro sforzo è
riuscire a lavorare anche con alto
livello di contenuto simbolico riuscire
a far appropriare quello che stiamo
facendo dalla comunità stessa in cui
andiamo a lavorare per questo creiamo
dei processi di partecipazione
lavoriamo insieme loro imparano
costruiscono abbiamo fatto spesso delle
scuole le scuole nei propri figli e con
queste scuole
loro riescono con questo processo loro
riescono a fare proprio e costruiamo un
forte senso di identità all'interno
delle comunità in cui lavoriamo
se avete presente che spesso lavoriamo
in piccoli villaggi dove non si parla
inglese si parla solo il dialetto spesso
del luogo in cui siamo
lavoriamo molto nei villaggi beduini
quindi in situazioni molto distanti da
quello che è il normale modo di lavorare
in cui potremo lavorare da questa parte
del mondo dal mondo occidentale
quindi è molto importante riuscire a
trovare un canale di comunicazione che
se intuitivo che sia facile non deve
avere una grafica accattivante per noi
deve essere una grafica chiara in cui
mostriamo gli strumenti cosa serve come
si utilizza qual è il risultato finale
scendendo il processo po come faceva
hitchcock nei suoi film
e questo il viaggio vero e proprio
questo è
e il momento in cui costruiamo con la
comunità quindi definiamo una tecnica la
proponiamo la innoviamo e cominciamo a
costruire con la comunità
qui questo è un processo realizzato
all'interno della striscia di gaza la
striscia di gaza come potete immaginare
il conflitto è molto forte e letterale
si tratta di guerra bombardano sparano è
una questi tuazione molto difficile è
difficile entrare dentro la striscia di
gaza
hai bisogno di un visto particolare che
dura un tempo molto molto contingentato
per cui noi in quel tempo dobbiamo
riuscire a finire il lavoro che ci siamo
proposti per cui con persone che spesso
sono persone che non hanno mai lavorato
nell'edilizia non hanno mai costruito
nulla sono magari i padri dei bambini
che poi andranno a scuola dobbiamo
riuscire a organizzare un lavoro quindi
dobbiamo essere tedeschi in contesti in
cui non c'è assolutamente organizzazione
ma ci proviamo e in questo caso ci siamo
riusciti
non trovavamo materiali
l'approvvigionamento dei materiali non
c'era abbiamo trovato questi sacchi e
attraverso una reinterpretazione di una
tecnica che arriva dalla costruzione di
trincee basicamente abbiamo costruito
una scuola abbiamo costruito comunità
l'intero villaggio ha contribuito a
costruire questa questa scuola insieme a
noi
quindi questo rimando costante
nell'andare tornare nell'essere
nell'essere qui costruire il workshop
verificare tornare e realizzare l'opera
con la comunità conquistiamo con cui
stiamo lavorando e soprattutto costruire
nuovi simboli nuovi simboli per la
comunità in cui andiamo a lavorare
questo edificio è un edificio
estremamente performante dal punto di
vista del comfort termico e della
possibilità di utilizzare tutte le
risorse a disposizioni in quello
specifico contesto ma oltre a quello è
anche un evocare quello che erano i
caratteri culturali della cultura in cui
andavamo a lavorare che in questo caso
una cultura beduina un piccolo villaggio
beduino a nord della striscia di gaza
nomadi costretti alla stanzialità a
causa della guerra a causa di un limite
invalicabile costituito dal muro della
striscia di gaza che noi abbiamo cercato
di come dire reinterpretare con questo
tetto quindi il tetto diventa l'evocare
la tenda beduina che però diventa anche
l'inclinazione corretta per riuscire a
raccogliere l'acqua piovana in una
situazione in cui l'acqua è un reale
problema ma è anche l'inclinazione
corretta per installare il primo
impianto fotovoltaico all'interno della
striscia di gaza e quindi essere più
efficiente possibile per cui c'è sempre
questo rimando tra tecnica e
composizione tra ricerca del bello
ricerca della della composizione
architettonica e soluzione tecnica dei
problemi nella direzione di un progetto
che possa dare un reale beneficio alla
comunità
l'edificio che è chiuso che si chiude
dall'esterno dalla non qualità
dell'esterno e si introverse in una
sorta di piccolo paradiso creato
all'interno questo è un asilo in centro
per le donne come voi potete immaginare
le donne in un posto in un luogo come
gaza non vive proprio non vivono proprio
nella situazione di comfort uno dei
grandi dei grandi risultati che che mi
sento di aver ottenuto in questo
progetto e che le donne le maestre le
mamme dei bambini riuscivano a essere
realmente a loro agio all'interno della
questa scuola è una scuola in cui
abbiamo abbiamo inserito un impianto di
fitodepurazione depurazione delle acque
la raccolta dell'acqua piovana dicevo il
fotovoltaico
i muri sono estremamente performanti dal
punto di vista dell'isolamento termico e
e la luce naturale e misurata
correttamente per riuscire a raggiungere
i risultati migliori e non utilizzare la
luce elettrica è un edificio piuttosto
autarchico giustamente per il contesto
in cui siamo un edificio che costruisce
veramente comunità che risponde alle
funzioni per cui è stato costruito
dicevo donne e asilo è un edificio che
incontra incontra due culture e incontra
le persone che lo che l'hanno
frequentato è un edificio realmente
sostenibile in cui i tre pilastri della
sostenibilità sono realmente in grado di
convivere non c'è sostenibilità senonchè
sostenibilità ambientale economica e
sociale
questo lo ripeterò sempre per cui
l'aspetto economico è fondamentale noi
cerchiamo di ottimizzare i processi
costruttivi in modo da riuscire arginare
il più possibile i costi e riuscire poi
ad avere sempre comunque un livello di
performance molto molto molto alto ma
questa scuola come spesso accade in
contesti di guerra è stata distrutta nel
2014 nella l'invasione di terra del 2014
ha resistito a tre bombardamenti senza
aver nessun tipo di danno ma nel 2014
sono entrati con i carri armati
caterpillar hanno tirato giù al suolo
tutto è una cosa stata una cosa
estremamente drammatica come potete
immaginare per noi per la fatica che ci
è costato e per la comunità intera
ancora di più chiaramente però noi
stiamo forse più tenaci della guerra e
siamo tornati e l'abbiamo costruita
un'altra con un'altra tecnica con un alt
con altri materiali abbiamo lasciato un
know how diverso quindi adesso conoscono
due tecniche diverse che possono essere
gestite autonomamente dalle comunità in
questo momento i bambini continuano ad
andare a scuola
in questa nuova scuola
[Applauso]